es difícil ser el último
porque han habido tan buenas
presentaciones tan alegres tan
simpáticas tan profundas y yo tengo algo
que no cumple exactamente con el
contenido que pide hacer porque tiene
que ser una propuesta innovadora
y la mía no es innovadora
pero si tiene que ser algo que cambie la
sociedad y la mía si cambia la sociedad
entonces
les quiero contar
porque creo que el concepto de feliz
trabajo es absolutamente indispensable
hoy día en nuestro país
cuando ustedes quieren ser infelices
paren la mano cuantos quieren ser
infelices en la vida
para qué
cuando ustedes quieren ser felices la
vida puede levantar la mano
la gran mayoría y bien
entonces ustedes están haciendo sentido
a lo que aristóteles hace 24 siglos dijo
que el sentido último y primordial de
nuestra vida era ser felices
y a lo que las naciones unidas hace
siete años declaró
como una derecho un derecho humano
fundamental que debe ser respetado que
es la felicidad y la satisfacción en el
trabajo
entonces la pregunta es donde tenemos
que ser felices en qué momento
porque el recurso más escaso que tenemos
los seres humanos es el tiempo
porque el tiempo es finito
el tiempo de cada día finito el de la
semana es finito el del mes el del año
desde la vida de cada uno de nosotros
entonces hay que pensar en qué momento
vamos a ser felices
donde estamos más tiempo cuánto tiempo
le dedican ustedes a lo que más les
gusta
el hobby que más le gusta
algunos será el fútbol otro será ver
películas andar en bicicleta el yoga el
gimnasio correr cuánto tiempo le dedica
uno de lunes a viernes a esa actividad a
la que más le apasiona en la vida
una hora una hora impide un juego 22
corriendo
de luna viene
cuanto tiempo se dedica a eso el sábado
cuatro horas tres horas cinco horas
domingo cuatro horas cinco horas si
llegáramos dos horas de lunes a viernes
más cuatro o cinco horas a dos serían 20
horas
cuánto tiempo dedicamos a nuestros
afectos a la persona oa las personas que
nos llenan el corazón a los hijos a la
pareja a la persona a la cual tamos
enamorado que nos mueve
de lunes a viernes 2 horas
tal vez
un sábado en domingo 5 horas 6 horas si
sumamos eso también de alrededor de 20
entonces pensemos ahora
cuanto tiempo estamos trabajando en
nuestro país
las investigaciones y los estudios dicen
que es habitual que las personas salgan
de su casa a las siete y media de la
mañana
y vuelvan alrededor de las siete y media
de la tarde el tiempo está al lado
obviamente que hay que agregar solo al
trabajo
tiempo que además es un gran generador
de estrés
el metro y transantiago los buses el
colectivo los tacos son cuidados de
estrés otra persona sabe en la noche y
media llegan a las ocho y media noche
otros trabajan en un bol y entra en el
rol de las diez y media aparecen a diez
y media de la noche en su casa otros son
guardias pero hacen aseo y trabajan de 8
8 o de 12 a 12
por lo tanto en la semana trabajamos 60
horas 12 horas por 5 sin pensar que
algunos trabajan sábado e incluso
pensamos en el trabajo lo saben los
domingos por lo tanto son 60 horas
60 horas son más que lo que le dedicamos
nuestro ser más querido a nuestros
jóvenes es el 60 por ciento del tiempo e
incluso un poco más de eso
entonces la pregunta es se puede ser
feliz en la vida si somos infelices en
este 60% del tiempo
creen ustedes que se puede
el ser humano no tiene la capacidad de
sentirse de esa forma por lo tanto si
somos infelices en nuestros 60 horas
si somos felices el 60% de nuestro
tiempo si nos sentimos abusados si nos
sentimos no visibilizados si no sentimos
que estamos con un jefe que no nos
quiere y que nos reta y que nos hace mal
lo que ocurre en ese tiempo es que para
ser finalmente lo que ocurra el luna
bien de nuestra vida hay un estudio de
una universidad prestigiosa chilena que
es una cosa tremenda que el 70 el 70% de
los chilenos de lunes a viernes sólo
tiene tiempo de trabajar trasladarse y
comer
nada más que eso las cosas bien
entretenía fuera que preocupantes a esa
consideración pero el 70 por ciento de
las personas de una vivienda sólo tiene
tiempo de trabajar para darse y comer
ahora
trabajamos
2000 horas en chile más menos somos el
quinto país que más trabaja de la ocde y
venimos mejorando porque fuimos cuarto y
tercero en las dos últimas estadísticas
de la ocde somos el quinto entre 36
países
trabajamos demasiado
trabajamos demasiado y para una
productividad absolutamente insuficiente
chile ha sido reiteradamente mientras
del año 1990 el año 2003 y el año 2014
penúltimo en productiva en la ocde sólo
superamos a méxico que es el que más
trabaja solo hay un país que gana que
trabaja 2200 horas que en méxico después
estamos nosotros quintos que trabajamos
2000 méxico el mayor productivo chile es
el siguiente a méxico reiterado en 25
años cambiando los sistemas políticos
cambiando el país cambiando la
circunstancia seguimos siendo penúltimos
cuál es la percepción entonces que
tenemos la persona en ese trabajo
la percepción que tienen las personas de
este trabajo es que en un 60% no les
gusta el trabajo
y la gran mayoría tampoco les gusta en
la empresa en la cual trabajan por lo
tanto el lugar donde estamos
desarrollando es más bien
insatisfactorio
y el estilo del jefe o el supervisor va
descendiendo también hacia hacer un 60
por ciento bastante insatisfactorio
el jefe estudiante hacer mando militar
desconfiado no respetuoso no cariñoso no
un líder no empático por lo tanto
incluso hay una estadística
norteamericana que dice que es tanto lo
que odia la gente el jefe que un 20 por
ciento de los millenials matarían al
jefe matarían a su jefe es tanto el
desagrado de ese contacto cinco días a
la semana 12 horas con esa persona que
sabe más yo no elegiría para para
terminar con él
entonces la percepción de respecto al
trabajo es evidentemente mala y la
percepción del liderazgo no sólo del
jefe sino que de los gerentes y los de
los dueños la empresa es bastante
paupérrima en general las personas no
quieren parecerse siquiera a ese dueño
de empresa oa ese gerente porque no
quieren tener ese estilo de vida que es
con muchos recursos pero presos de una
infelicidad totalmente evidente
con eso nuestro país se mueve entonces
en una productiva baja en personas
infelices y el trabajo que son
insatisfactorios
y como ya lo vimos anteriormente
también en problemas serios de salud
cuando crece la diabetes cuando crece el
sobrepeso cuando el chile crece el
suicidio cuanto crece el consumo de
fármacos en forma significativa lo que
está ocurriendo es que eso evidentemente
desde mi punto de vista es el efecto de
personas que estamos excesivamente en
trabajos que son insatisfactorios con
jefes que son desagradables y donde no
tenemos ningún espacio para
desarrollarnos y pensar que estamos
siendo felices
entonces
cuando eso es lo que ocurren en el día a
día la pregunta es si existe
alternativas si existen cosas que se
puedan hacer a esto
yo participé de un proyecto de una
empresa donde si era posible ser feliz
donde si era posible tener alta
productividad donde pib el dios de
ciencias médicas era un 1% lo más bajo
que ha tenido una empresa en este país y
no solo es esa empresa hay muchas otras
empresas que también lo logran hacer en
chile en latinoamérica en eeuu y en
europa se puede se puede entonces
estamos
casualmente metidos en un paradigma de
una forma de hacer empresas que no es la
que corresponde feliz gran fele trabajo
es confianza es respeto
feliz trabajo es positividad es mando
democrático es consideración
horizontalidad amor hacia el trabajador
eso feliz trabajo esa es la propuesta
es posible hacer yo le pido entonces al
ministerio del trabajo y al ministerio
de salud en chile que tomen una
consideración importante respecto a la
felicidad del trabajo que se puede hacer
mejor que tomen un índice que nos
permita medir el sentido más importante
que tenemos los chilenos para estar en
ser feliz en el día a día entonces por
qué no medir la felicidad en el trabajo
que nos permitiría mejorar la salud que
nos permitiría mejorar la productividad
porque esto es método científico yo le
podría decir
infinitos estudios él podría poner acá
50 estudios de universidades de
consultoras de primer nivel de grupos de
científicos de primer nivel que dice que
personas que son respetadas personas que
son tratadas con confianza personas que
son tratadas con positividad personas
que viven en el afecto y por qué no en
el amor en el trabajo tienen alto nivel
de productividad
de aena y este número de lo que pasa
cuando la gente se siente cuidada porque
no cuidar a las personas en el lugar de
trabajo cuando se siente respetada
cuando se siente en el cariño cómo
cambia el resultado de una compañía
entonces el método científico es muy
claro 50 estudios yo te digo que me
pongan un estudio de una universidad
seria de un grupo de científicos serios
que diga que las personas maltratadas
tratadas con la tico no visibilizada por
su jefe presionadas en exceso con mando
militar
producen más
yo reto a cualquiera de los dueños de
empresas cualquiera de la persona que
está hoy día dirigiendo el país que diga
que eso dónde hay un estudio que diga
eso entonces lo curioso es eso aquellos
métodos que claramente identificables
que se puede producir hay países que lo
han hecho y sin embargo los mismos
dueños de empresas que tienen magíster y
que tienen grandes estudios doctorados
por el cual hacen negocios por el método
científico lo que está demostrado es lo
que hacen en los negocios sin embargo es
lo que es gestionar personas hacen todo
lo contrario y hacer exactamente el
método que permite que la gente no sea
productiva hace exactamente el método
para que la gente se enferme hace
exactamente el método para que las
personas sean infelices cuál es la
explicación de eso es muy difícil de
entender entonces yo pido gestión del
cambio y que el principal cambio no
parta que el que se desvía a los
trabajadores o el que celebra los
millennials o que se le pide al último
nivel de la empresa se lo pido a los
gerentes generales a los dueños de
empresas a los ministros de este país y
el principal cambio es hacer gestión del
cambio respecto de cómo se trabaja con
las personas y tomar la definición de
trabajar con las personas en positividad
el cariño el afecto en confianza el
respeto
en todos los seres los elementos y está
totalmente demostrado y generan mejor
productividad y hay demostraciones esto
se ha hecho por ejemplo cuando yo estaba
en el colegio
cuando tenía ocho años mi profesora
tenía un pan o un palo en el escritorio
y cuando uno llegaba tarde o se
equivocaba en algo o molestaba al
compañero
la profesora tomada del palo como está
aquí
y le pegaba un palo y a mí me tocaron
muchos palos y a todos mi compañero de
tocar un palo y nadie lo escuchaba ni
raro era parte del del escenario y
cuando no estaba el palo se le perdía
por avance o se lo escondía moss tenía
la mano
y además no se usaba no cierto para el
palmetazo en la cara y yo no sabía
muchos días con una de las mejillas
coloradas
si eso ocurriera hoy día
adrián en la puerta del colegio mamás
con pancartas abría peticiones de que
salga el profesor que salga la directora
del colegio y que incluso lo metan preso
abriendo intención no se tomen a los
presos eso ocurriría que pasó la
educación micro micro desde desde la
dureza del palo y de la de la mano y del
del alumno con la cuestión de burro en
la esquina hacia el afecto hacia el
cariño hace un método mucho más
afectuoso cariñoso cercano que ha
significado una mejor educación
en esa misma época porque yo tenía ocho
años mi padre tenía un jefe
y el jefe era dictatorial era poco
respetuoso
desconfiaba
y una persona distante absolutamente y
que su mensaje habitual era si no te
gusta te va a ir y puse termino contrato
de trabajo y ni conozco ni sé cómo te
llaman así era el jefe que tenía mi
padre de hace 50 años el burro acá y veo
cómo son los jefes del día
siguen usando exactamente el si no te
gusta te vai siguen usando exactamente
el poco termina tu contrato de trabajo
siguen usando exactamente que ni
siquiera sé cómo te llaman y no me
importa
así son mayoritariamente los jefes
sensibles
entonces bien por la educación que
cambió su modalidad y los profesores ya
no tienen ni palo ni usar la mano y mal
por el mundo laboral que ha mantenido
una modalidad que explica la
improductividad que explica los malos
resultados y que explica lo que pasa en
la salud
entonces feliz trabajo es confianza
feliz trabajo el sentido compartido
feliz trabajo es una fórmula
infinitamente científica clara y fácil
para nuestra compañía que han mostrado
éxito que han mostrado resultados que
han mostrado que han mejorado lo que es
trabajar en el día a día en forma
significativa afortunadamente crecen las
empresas y los rankings que hacen y que
generan el feliz trabajo se puede medir
y se puede identificar exactamente cuál
es el jefe que genera feliz trabajo y el
jefe que genera la infelicidad entonces
mi propuesta es feliz y trabajo para
todos
feliz trabajo para cada joven tres días
está ingresando al mundo laboral como
millennial y que merece una experiencia
de trabajo distinta
para cada viejo y ya no hace nuevo poder
jubilar a los 60 y 65 sino que
probablemente tiene que seguir
trabajando hasta los 75
para cada hombre
para cada mujer que cada día más se
integra potentemente al mundo laboral y
tomando además cargo de más
responsabilidad y también para cada
persona que tiene una elección sexual
distinta y que tiene todo el derecho a
tener el mejor feliz trabajo en la
empresa donde esté para cada
peruano que se ha integrado a la fuerza
laboral chilena
para cada colombiano para cada cristiano
que es parte de esta sociedad hoy en día
se trata de respeto
se trata de afecto se trata de cariño se
trata de elementos que son totalmente
claros como los que te dejan visibilizar
al trabajador
mi propuesta concreta es feliz trabajo
para todos porque el feliz trabajo va a
cambiar la sociedad chilena en
productividad en salud y en felicidad
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]